qu'est-ce que tu voulais avant Miami
je voulais juste échapper à
ma vie  J'étais vraiment
[Musique]
allons-y
pourquoi es-tu à Londres Je vais faire un
spectacle dans ce célèbre théâtre
déconnecté nous pouvons les réveiller avec une
vague de passion qu'ils n'ont jamais ressentie
avant l'
enfer ouais sans plus tarder je te donne
la mine magique de l'artiste visionnaire
personne ne croit en moi comme ta mère
a
donc quel est le spectacle à ce sujet c'est pareil
ou va-t-elle se marier pour l'amour ou l'argent alors
que choisit-elle
Ed la vraie question est pourquoi a-t-elle l'
impression qu'elle doit le choisir
il me semble que c'est utilisé pour lâcher prise
[Musique]
et un peu de bien
peut-être aussi
[Musique]
tu ne m'arrêtes pas pas cette
fois tu es si bon à ça Je ne vais pas
simplement nous laisser abandonner  Je veux que
chaque femme qui entre dans ce
théâtre sente qu'une femme  peut avoir ce
qu'elle veut quand elle veut